foreign
if you're worried that people in our
country are not focused enough on their
phones are not absorbed enough in
technology to the exclusion of everyone
and everything else if you're deeply
concerned that we are not isolated
enough
that we're not doing enough to block out
the real world in favor of our
electronic devices if you are the sort
of person who wakes up in the middle of
the night in a cold sweat terrified that
we are not all devoting enough of Our
Lives to staring at our screens if your
biggest complaint about the modern world
is that we all spend too much time
touching grass and not nearly enough
time with our faces buried in our phones
then well Apple has some good news for
you introducing Apple Vision Pro which
is the tech Giants quote-unquote
revolutionary new spatial computer
otherwise known as a phone that you wear
directly on your face
Business Wire has more quote Apple today
unveiled Apple Vision Pro a
revolutionary spatial computer that
seamlessly Blends digital content with
the physical world while allowing users
to stay present and connected to others
Vision Pro creates an infinite canvas
for apps that scales beyond the
boundaries of a traditional display and
introduces a fully a fully
three-dimensional user interface
controlled by the most natural intuitive
inputs possible a user's eyes hands and
voice featuring Vision OS the world's
first spatial operating system Vision
Pro lets users interact with digital
content in a way that feels like it is
physically present in their space the
Breakthrough design of Vision Pro
features an ultra high resolution
display system that packs 23 million
pixels across two displays and uh custom
Apple silicon in a unique dual chip
design to ensure every experience feels
like it's taking place in front of the
user's eyes in real time
now it's a lot of fancy words describing
what is undoubtedly a fancy device but
not really revolutionary apple is not
inventing anything new here these big
dumb looking nerd goggles have existed
for a while and I've been making people
look like dorks from the future for a
while these nerd goggles aren't
different in kind but they are fancier
and much more expensive hitting the
market at thirty five hundred dollars a
pop
or what the average American might know
as two months of mortgage payments
of course in these tough Economic Times
the only people who should be spending
thirty five hundred dollars on a toy are
like millionaires
yet if history is any guide lots of
non-millionaires lots and lots of them
will line up to spend money that they
don't have on this bull they don't need
and which won't make their lives better
in any substantive way and then many of
those same people will complain that
they need help paying off their student
loans
anyway if you want to know more about
the nerd goggles here's a promo video
that Apple played for a large crowd
yesterday watch
your surroundings become an infinite
canvas you
th anywhere and make them any size you
want
capture photos and videos and relive
your most important memories in an
entirely new way
watch your movies shows and sports and
immerse yourself in games on a giant
screen surrounded by special audio
yes immerse yourself in the screen live
inside the screen be the screen
block out everything but the screen
copulate with the screen and make little
screen babies and start a screen family
together to replace the real family that
you're neglecting
there's a lot more to learn about these
screens these are very special screens
indeed
even more special than the last really
special screen that Apple made
for more information on the screen
here's another promo video this one
gives perhaps the best look at the
technical capabilities of these nerd
goggles and also the deepest
appreciation for just how stupid they
make people look watch
[Music]
[Applause]
who wants to sit on their couch wearing
that on their face
now you're starting out in your career
you're trying to find a job it's so
important to stand out from the crowd
also really difficult uh especially
these days given how much competition
there is standing out can be tough
especially when you're looking for a job
or when you're hiring looking to find
that application that really stands out
that's why you need to check out
ZipRecruiter zip recruiter helps you
find the most qualified people for your
roles fast right now you can try
ZipRecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com Welsh ziprecruiters
matching technology helps you find the
most qualified candidates for a wide
range of roles see a candidate you like
well you can easily send them a personal
invite so they're more likely to apply
their user-friendly dashboard makes it
easy to filter review and rate your
candidates all from one place let zip
recruiter help you find the best people
for all of your roles four out of five
employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
see for yourself go to ziprecruiter.com
walls to try ZipRecruiter for free again
at ziprecruiter.com
w-a-l-s-h zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
who wants to walk around their house
looking like a
reject from the X-Men
they truly do look very very stupid and
this is the one fact that I still hang
my hopes on maybe the nerd goggles will
fail to take off simply because they're
ugly and awkward and anyone who wears
them looks like a huge dork perhaps our
vanity will win out in a war with our
materialism we can only hope
but there are other problems aside from
the fact that they make you look like
the sort of person who um you know sits
alone at the lunch table and gets
bullied and shoved in a locker a locker
uh perhaps problems even more
significant than that if you can believe
it problems like the final and total
forfeiture of any semblance of privacy
or autonomy
Apple says that it's nerd goggles will
offer you an augmented reality but Apple
can't augment your reality without first
having total unfettered access to it
so with the nerd goggles Apple can see
everything you see it can literally
track every movement you make it can
track where your eyes move you are
granting them access to every part of
your life every movement not to mention
every part of your home
now hopefully if you've been paying
attention at all for the past 20 years
you know this is not some kind of
paranoid conspiracy theory big Tech
tracks catalog stores and monetizes
every piece of you that it has access to
if you wear their devices on your face
and literally experience your everyday
physical reality through one of their
filters you will have granted them
access to everything
everything
not to mention by the way what about
people who are walking past you while
you're wearing the dumb things
like if I have to walk past you while
you're wearing the nerd goggles am I now
it's like how do I know if I'm being uh
recorded if I'm if I you know is that
image now stored somewhere
it takes everything there will be almost
nothing left privacy wise except the
thoughts inside your mind
and they'll get those too sooner rather
than later
and somehow this is not even the biggest
problem with the nerd goggles the
biggest problem is that they represent
one more step away from reality away
from the physical real world
the nerd goggles promise to augment our
reality which is to make it better and
greater that's what augment means
and it plans to do this by adding more
screens to it
by making life more convenient
by giving you fewer reasons to get off
your couch
I don't consider this an improvement
over actual reality
okay there are plenty of problems with
our reality none of which can be solved
by the nerd goggles
but the one thing we can say about the
world the real actual physical world is
that it's a big place it's a dynamic and
interesting place a place of endless
possibility and real breathtaking Beauty
argument
like you're in your house with your
children you need to augment that
reality
yeah I'm sort of bored here in my own
home experiencing the love of my family
I need to augment this reality you know
what this reality means it needs screens
yeah I'm looking at one of my children
but what it'd be so much better if there
was a screen there
can I make my child into an app
I can just store my loved ones on apps
I don't even near I don't need real
loved ones actually I just I need an app
there's an app for that
just click the app and no it's my child
okay put them back in the app
if you want augmentation go outside
you dork go hike a mountain go to the
beach go do anything do something engage
with your actual surroundings engage
with the human beings in your
surroundings especially the ones in your
own home
we already spend far too much time with
our faces buried in our phones this
already has the effect of isolating us
of de-prioritizing the people who are
physically closest to us now we'll have
our phones attached to our faces which
will only make this Dynamic worse
which makes me reconsider something
because I just said that eventually big
Tech will figure out a way to read our
thoughts
but maybe not you know after all they
can't access our thoughts if we don't
have any thoughts to begin with and this
is how we're apparently working around
that problem by becoming increasingly
comatose and numb slack jawed staring at
screens experiencing only what the
screens want us to experience thinking
nothing in particular developing no
unique thoughts of Our Own no inner life
no real identity
and so there are no thoughts see this is
the great irony soon enough they will
figure out a way to read our minds and
they'll probably do it so those dumb
things you're wearing on your head but
by then our minds will be empty vessels
they'll get access to our thoughts and
there'll just be nothing there
nothing left to read
the devices will have already become our
minds
we will be digitally lobotomized
a bunch of drooling senile vegetables
with big dumb goggles on our face
staring at screens that only we can see
isolated from everybody all of us fat
and disgusting wasting away
but too distracted to notice
and too numb to care
in other words I don't plan to purchase
the Apple Vision Pro
in fact they are today
and everyone who wears them
or also canceled if you'd like to see
what else I have to say you can access
my full show by going to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt wall Show
Twitter page hope to see you there
Godspeed